[Musique]
il s'est d'abord fait connaître comme
chercheur spécialiste des relations
internationales mais un chercheur engagé
presque militant rien de bien étonnant
puisqu'il baigne dans la politique
depuis ses 18 ans
[Musique]
bonjour Benjamin Haddad bonjour alors il
y a une anecdote qui m'a fait sourire
quand j'ai préparé l'émission je me suis
penché un peu sur vos débuts en
politique c'est la réaction de votre
mère quand vous lui avez dit que vous
vouliez prendre votre carte dans un
parti alors que vous étiez encore au
lycée je crois oui moi j'ai été élevé
par des parents qui ont la passion du
travail des études et donc sa réaction
c'était passe ton bac et puis Sciences
Po d'abord donc j'ai pris j'ai toujours
été passionné d'engagement et de
politique mais j'ai pris ma carte une
fois en création et qu'est-ce qui vous
rendez si impatient de vous engager
comme ça en politique j'ai toujours eu
cette passion je pense que en plus j'ai
fait mon lycée à un moment qui était
très politisé Jean-Marie Le Pen est
passé au second tour en 2002 j'ai eu mon
bac en 2003 on avait eu le 11 septembre
beaucoup de sujets qui étaient très
intenses à ce moment-là à la fois on
peut utiliser en relation internationale
je pense qu'à un moment l'engagement on
a ça en soi on a envie de donner un sens
à sa vie qui peut être dépasse
simplement sa propre personnalité j'ai
passé beaucoup en tant que militant
engagé jeune populaire effectivement à
l'UMP les jeunes de l'UMP les jeunes de
l'UMP qui étaient présidé à l'époque par
Marie gevenot qui est aujourd'hui député
de notre groupe Renaissance
à tracter à coller des affiches à écumer
les meetings participés à la campagne de
Nicolas Sarkozy
21 ans et alors vous avez pas participé
en petites mains vous avez rédigé des
notes et même des discours sur tout le
volet international diplomatique j'étais
déjà passionné par l'International
j'avais fait un stage dans un film tank
américain en 3ème année de Sciences Po
et c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé à
travailler avec David Martinon qui était
le conseiller diplomatique de Nicolas
Sarkozy qui avait organisé une petite
équipe pour préparer le programme de
politique étrangère des notes des
discours des éléments de langage et donc
j'ai participé de ce côté là mais aussi
évidemment en tant que en tant que
militant très actif sur le terrain David
Martinon vous l'avez suivi ensuite dans
sa campagne malheureuse aux municipales
à Neuilly-sur-Seine vous étiez dans une
dans son équipe et puis à partir de 2009
et bien c'est en première ligne que vous
êtes apparu en temps que jeune copéiste
je voulais juste dire un petit mot de
génération France et de génération
France jeunes puis la plupart d'entre
vous connaissez qui est un film tank
donc un cercle de réflexion qui a été
créé par Jean-François Copé depuis
quelques années pour promouvoir le débat
pour ouvrir au maximum la réflexion
politique à la société civile aux
entrepreneurs aux intellectuels aux
jeunes à tous ces acteurs faut pas
forcément l'habitude de s'engager dans
les partis politiques de prendre leur
carte d'arriver dans une logique
militante partisane et les faire
participer au débat public alors à cette
époque vous étiez donc le responsable du
mouvement génération France un signe
tank comme vous dites donc un cercle de
réflexion il y en a eu deux autres par
la suite on va en parler des signes tank
pour certains la politique c'est avant
tout l'action on a l'impression que pour
vous c'est d'abord la réflexion
l'intellectualisation non c'est l'action
au service des idées je l'ai toujours
été engagé militant pour mes convictions
un peu spectateurs engagés
pour défendre mes idées et l'engagement
politique où là on a quand même des
leviers concrets d’actions opérationnels
pour pouvoir agir et c'est bien
l'objectif par la suite Jean-François
Copé a misé sur vous quand il a pris la
tête de l'UMP et vous a nommé secrétaire
national et vous pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez misé sur Jean-François Copé à
l'époque c'est quelqu'un pour qui j'ai
toujours beaucoup d'amitié moi j'ai été
à l'UMP parce que je suis un libéral un
réformateur un européen il incarnait ça
il avait aussi su donner beaucoup de
dynamisme au groupe à l'époque c'est
l'assemblée effectivement il était
président du groupe
UMP à l'Assemblée nationale qui était je
crois un groupe qui était assez actif
voire autonome donc je t'ai assez attiré
par ça et puis il y avait en effet ce
film tank on faisait venir des gens de
gauche de droite des experts de la
société civile pour débattre l'envoi des
images d'un débat sur l'éducation
nationale par exemple donc je trouve que
c'était une période assez stimulante
intellectuellement on en revient
toujours aux idées en 2014 vous demandez
à Jean-François Copé de vous envoyer en
Ukraine alors qu'on est en soulèvement
de la population plasmaidan à Kiev vous
y allez au nom de l'UMP pour rencontrer
les parties d'opposition vous dites que
ce voyage a été le tournant de votre
engagement qu'est-ce que vous entendez
par là pour plusieurs raisons déjà ça a
été un moment passionnant intense très
émouvant vous avez cette place Maiden à
Kiev ou des dizaines de milliers de
jeunes viennent se rassembler pendant
des mois il fait moins 15 degrés dans
des tentes avec des drapeaux européens
c'est la première fois de l'histoire que
des gens se font cibler tués parce qu'il
grandissent le drapeau européen qui pour
eux et la promesse d'un meilleur avenir
de la démocratie de la lutte contre la
corruption et d'un avenir européen à ce
moment là il faut quand même rappeler on
est en 2014 en France on place le Front
national en tête de l'élection
européenne on est en Europe juste avant
le brexit blasé cynique par rapport à
l'idéal européen qui viennent nous
rappeler les jeunes Ukrainiens donc
c'était un moment très fort et c'est un
moment où j'ai voulu m'éloigner de la
politique la plus classique
c'est là où vous dites que ce Maiden
vous a rendu à nouveau idéaliste et la
conclusion et la leçon que vous en tirez
c'est de quitter la politique c'est
étonnant et c'est vrai que c'est un
moment où comme beaucoup de collègues de
gauche comme de droite je ne
reconnaissais plus dans ce que le
clivage droite-gauche traditionnel avait
offrir je voyais la droite l'UMP qui
était prise dans des querelles de
personnalité et d'égo qui commence à se
crisper notamment sur les questions
d'identité et de société j’étais
favorable au mariage pour tous et j'ai
vu beaucoup de dirigeants de droite
allaient dans les manifestations les
unes après les autres donc je me
reconnaissais plus et c'est là que j'ai
décidé de prendre du du recul donc vous
partez à Washington vous devenez
chercheur dans le signe tank américain
qui est baptisé Hudson institut est-ce
que vous voyez ça comme une autre forme
d'engagement que la politique on a le
sentiment que que vous êtes vraiment
chercheur engagé enfin que oui
absolument déjà j'arrive à un moment
passionnant j'arrive fin 2014 quelques
mois plus tard Donald Trump déclare sa
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
début 2015 pendant un an et demi tous
mes amis américains républicains comme
démocrates nous disent il n'a aucune
chance il va imploser
et donc je crois que c'était un
avertissement évidemment pour l'Europe
et après ça d'ailleurs j'ai toujours
considéré que Marine Le Pen les
populistes pouvaient l'emporter et donc
il fallait rester engagé et puis j'ai
considéré que Trump était pas un
accident de l'histoire qu'on voyait une
continuité aux États-Unis un repli des
Américains sur eux-mêmes un retrait
d'Europe une volonté de plus intervenir
dans des conflits au Moyen-Orient ou
ailleurs qui avaient parfois des
conséquences sur notre sécurité donc il
fallait que les Européens en tirent les
conclusions ce qui est étonnant c'est
que ce premier sing tank donc Hudson
institut puis le second qui s'appelle
Atlantique Council sont clairement des
cercles de réflexion qu'on peut baptiser
d'atlantistes pro-américain et vous à
l'intérieur de ces salles de réflexion
vous êtes allé défendre l'Europe
l'Europe autonome l'Europe souveraine
indépendante l'Europe puissance vous en
ont pas un peu voulu vous les avez pas
un peu dérangé par rapport à ça j'ai
parfois été un petit peu le poil à
gratter mais je crois que j'ai quand
j'ai dirigé le Centre Europe de
l'atlanticoncil ce que j'ai convaincu de
faire c'est d'avoir un centre qui pour
la première fois aux États-Unis parler
de l'Union européenne parce que l'Europe
aux États-Unis c'était vu souvent à
travers l'OTAN ou à travers les
relations avec les États membres mais
l'Union européenne l'Union européenne
sur le plan de la régulation des
nouvelles technologies sur le plan
commercial sur le plan militaire les
Américains sont un peu schizophréniques
parce que ils disent d'un côté qui vont
se retirer d'Europe et qu'il faut que
les Européens investissent plus dans
leur propre sécurité leur propre défense
et tant mieux on est d'accord et dans le
même temps quand on le fait quand on
essaie d'unir l'Europe et d'avoir les
instruments de la souveraineté
généralement là
ibrac et voir si oppose donc je crois
qu'il y a un dialogue transatlantique
important à mettre en place avec nos
alliés entre alliés démocratique mais il
y a une relation à réinventer
repenser c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
faire des deux côtés de l'Atlantique ces
dernières années est-ce que vous avez
fait avec votre livre paru en avril 2019
paradis perdu vous évoquez d'un côté
l'avènement du trumpy et puis de l'autre
vous développez ce concept vous l'avez
pas inventé il est émergé quelques
années plus tôt nous concept d'autonomie
stratégique or il se trouve que cette
mois plus tard c'est Manuel Macron
lui-même qui en parle dans une interview
à The Economist
ce qu'il faut faire un lien entre les
deux est-ce que vous étiez resté en
contact avec lui parce que vous l'avez
rencontré à Washington dès 2015 et
est-ce que vous lui aviez envoyé votre
livre est-ce que vous avez pu
l'influencer là-dessus Emmanuel Macron
est quelqu'un qui s'intéresse beaucoup à
ses débats et assez et à ces questions
et il a mis évidemment l'Europe au coeur
de sa campagne moi c'est ce qui m'a
attiré dès 2017 en m'engageant depuis
les États-Unis à l'époque dans dans sa
campagne avec lui je crois qu'il est
hanté par l'idée que l'Europe pourrait
se retrouver à disparaître à être qu'un
un théâtre des rivalités entre les
États-Unis et la Chine sans être capable
d'avoir sa propre voix de défendre ses
intérêts vous avez nourri sa réflexion
sur ce sujet vous pensez je crois qu'il
se nourrit de beaucoup d'experts de
beaucoup de rencontres et d'échanges
c'est quelqu'un qui est toujours
extrêmement à l'écoute et ouvert assez à
ses échanges qui s'intéressent aux idées
alors vous l'avez dit votre rencontre
avec Emmanuel Macron est remonté à 2015
vous êtes engagé pour lui en 2017 à
Washington avec le comité en marche sur
place localement mais vous avez laissé
passer les législatives à l'époque pour
vous présenter finalement en 2022 vous
revenez en France vous présenter à Paris
dans le 16e arrondissement qu'est-ce qui
motive ce retour en politique alors que
vous aviez été quand même un peu échoé
déçu en 2015 je crois que les 5
prochaines années sont absolument
fondamentales pour le pays je crois que
il y a un risque de voir l'extrême
droite arriver au pays encore des
réformes fondamentales à faire au niveau
national mais bien sûr au niveau
européen vous savez moi je viens d'une
famille mon père est pas né en France
une famille qui s'est qui s'est intégrée
qui est qui a fui
l'antisémitisme en Tunisie qui est très
reconnaissante aussi à la République et
travailler dur pour s'intégrer donc je
me suis toujours aussi senti redevable
et donc cet engagement il a toujours été
en moi c'était le moment de franchir à
l'Assemblée vous présidez le groupe
d'amitié avec l'Ukraine vous avez
rencontré volo des meilleurs Hélène ce
qui a deux reprises avant d'être élu
député quand vous étiez à l'Atlantique
Council depuis que vous êtes député
également
cette guerre on Ukraine on a compris on
est consciente toutes les valeurs pour
lesquelles vous vous battez la liberté
l'Europe la démocratie mais est-ce que
cette bataille pour ses valeurs vous la
meniez pas de façon plus efficace en
tant que chercheur engagé chercheur
militants que de députés non je crois
que c'est des rôles différents mais dans
le cadre de l'assemblée nationale il y a
bien sûr un soutien à ce que fait la
France vous n'êtes pas aux commentaires
étrangères ou naturellement mais il y a
les livraisons d'armes le fond de
soutien à l'Ukraine qu'on a fait doubler
le groupe lors du débat budgétaire je
crois profondément à la diplomatie
parlementaire je pense que notre
Assemblée a un rôle à jouer dans ce
soutien à l'Ukraine et les Ukrainiens
d'ailleurs eux-mêmes sont reconnaissants
non seulement du soutien bien sûr de la
France mais aussi de ces échanges que
qui peuvent avoir avec les
parlementaires allez on va passer à
notre quiz à présent donc je vous
explique la règle je vais commencer des
phrases et ça va être à vous de les
compléter de les terminer on y va
depuis que je suis député j'évite de
j'évite de céder à la facilité de de la
violence du du clash c'est un c'est un
monde de conflits on se bat on se bat
pour pour des idées mais c'est un monde
qui peut aussi vite céder à conflit de
personnes et j'évite là un bon
porte-parole c'est comme un bon prof
vous êtes porte parole du groupe
Renaissance est-ce que c'est enseigné
c'est c'est différent parce que
moi j'ai toujours aimé l'enseignement
très interactif je faisais lire beaucoup
à mes à mes étudiants et après j'ai
essayé de les faire s'exprimer sur les
sujets je pense que c'est la meilleure
façon d'enseigner un porte-parole par
définition
mais en revanche alors il y a
effectivement la pédagogie vous avez
raison en revanche la politique c'est
énormément d'écoute faire une campagne
c'est en fait on parle moins je pense
que les gens qu'on veut on vient
rencontrer sur sur le terrain et ça ça
peut être proche d'un bon prof qui est
dans l'échange et dans la pédagogie mais
aussi l'écoute enfin ce qui me manque le
plus de la vie américaine c'est je ne
sais pas j'avais une vie intéressante et
agréable mais
sinon finalement vous préférez la vie
française bien sûr
bon merci beaucoup Benjamin adapte
d'être venu dans la politique et moi
merci à vous
[Musique]